This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This time of year, right in the middle of the holiday season, there's a beloved frenzy tradition playing out in Filipino households all around the world. Here it's explained, is reporter Gabrielle Burpee. Hello. Hi, Lola. Hi, how are you? I'm good. How are you?
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每到这个时候，也就是假日季的正当中，世界各地的菲律宾家庭都会上演一个备受喜爱的狂热传统。接下来由记者加布丽埃勒·伯皮为您解读。你好。嗨，罗拉。嗨，你好吗？我很好。你呢？我很好。
That, by the way, is Gabby's grandma. I'm good, okay. I just will came from the church. A few weeks ago I called my Lola to ask if she would be taking part in this annual tradition. Okay, so are you sending a ballot by-unbox this year? Do you know what ballot by-un box is? Are you quizzing me? The Balik Bayon box is the box that Filipinos abroad send to their relatives back in the Philippines. That's right. It's valid, it's returning, and Bayon is home like Philippines, that's my home. A Balic Bayon box is a huge cardboard box, usually over 100 pounds, that Filipinos living all over the world send to family members who are still living in the Philippines.
顺便说一下，那是加比的奶奶。我很好，没事。我刚从教堂回来。几个星期前，我打电话给我的罗拉，问她是否会参与这个年度传统。好吧，那你今年要寄巴里克巴延箱吗？你知道什么是巴里克巴延箱吗？你在考我吗？巴里克巴延箱就是海外菲律宾人寄给远在菲律宾的亲戚的箱子。没错。它是“巴里克”（balík），意思是返回，“巴延”（bayan）意思是家，比如菲律宾，那是我的家。巴里克巴延箱是一个巨大的纸板箱，通常重达100多磅，世界各地的菲律宾人都会把它们寄给仍然住在菲律宾的家人。
The word Balic Bayon literally means homecoming in Tagalog. When I was in the Philippines, it was Uncle Dennis who came here in America first. He was the one who first sent us a Balik Bayam box. To me, the Balik Bayam box, we always looking forward to it. Today, my Lola lives in the US, which means she's usually the one sending Balik Bayon boxes. But when she was still living in the Philippines, she remembers receiving them. Do you remember like the delivery person walking up to the door for... Yeah, we were so excited. Oh my gosh.
在他加禄语中，“巴里克巴延”这个词的字面意思是衣锦还乡。我在菲律宾时，是丹尼斯叔叔先来到美国的。他是第一个给我们寄巴里克巴延箱的人。对我来说，我们总是对巴里克巴延箱充满期待。今天，我的罗拉住在美国，这意味着通常是她寄出巴里克巴延箱。但当她还住在菲律宾时，她还记得收到过这些箱子。你还记得送货员走到门口的情景吗……对，我们太激动了。哦天哪。
The Balik Bayon box is usually delivered right to your door. Someone knocked on my door and the door answered and it said, delivery, June, I know the box from the from from for the end of the year. The family gathers around the box. So they all went down all the box and they were so happy, you know. And the box is filled with lots and lots of stuff from the US. They are full of chocolates, usually goods coming from Costco, the hand-me-down clothes, like jackets, sneakers, socks, books, electronics, game boy, even toothpaste, shampoo.
巴里克巴延箱通常会直接送到你家门口。有人敲了我的门，打开门，对方说：“有您的快递，琼，我知道这个年底的箱子。”全家人都围在箱子周围。所以他们都走下来看着那个箱子，他们太高兴了，你知道的。箱子里装满了来自美国的各种各样的东西。里面塞满了巧克力、通常来自好市多的商品、二手衣服（比如夹克、运动鞋、袜子）、书籍、电子产品、游戏机，甚至还有牙膏和洗发水。
And the most prized object in the box. Oh, this, like, that's spam. Spam is very expensive in the Philippines. Spam. And it's not just Gabby's family that does this. 400,000 of these ballot-bion boxes arrive in the Philippines from around the world every month. But right now, with the holidays, it's the busiest season. Mother is sending to sons, brothers, sisters, hundreds of thousands of people waiting in the
箱子里最珍贵的物品。哦，这个，就像是，那是午餐肉。午餐肉在菲律宾非常昂贵。午餐肉。不仅加比的家会这样做。每个月有40万个这样的巴里克巴延箱从世界各地运抵菲律宾。但现在正值假期，是一年中业务最繁忙的时期。母亲寄给儿子、兄弟、姐妹，成千上万的人在菲律宾等待着他们的箱子。
Philippines for their box. Hey guys, welcome back to my channel. So for today's video guys, I'm going to be showing you how I bought my Balakbion box On YouTube there are thousands of videos of people showing how to pack their box and the joys of Balakbion Boxing and Balakbion Unboxing I don't know how did I fit everything inside this box so much work but I'm'm sure it's gonna be worth it when I get there. Yay! I'm waiting for so long guys! Hello? Mommy? You're sending what? Oh my God!
嘿，大家好，欢迎回到我的频道。所以在今天的视频中，伙计们，我将向你们展示我是如何打包我的巴里克巴延箱的。在YouTube上有成千上万的视频，人们展示他们是如何打包箱子的，以及打包和拆箱巴里克巴延箱的乐趣。我不知道我是怎么把所有东西都塞进这个箱子的，花了好多功夫，但我相信当我到达那里时，这一切都是值得的。耶！我等了好久了，伙计们！喂？妈妈？你寄了什么？哦天哪！
You called and told me, Anakko is in. you Balik Bayon box. I'm getting Balik Bayon box. Send to me from my mom and brother. I will wait for a whole two months. Clearly, Filipinos love the Balik Bayon box. But I didn't even realize that it was something that was unique to us until I traveled to the Philippines for the first time when I was 12.
你打电话告诉我，我的孩子，你寄了巴里克巴延箱。我要收到巴里克巴延箱了。我妈妈和弟弟寄给我的。我要等整整两个月。显然，菲律宾人非常喜爱巴里克巴延箱。但直到我12岁第一次去菲律宾时，我甚至都没有意识到这是我们独有的东西。
I remember going to the airport in San Francisco, completely jittery for my first long haul international flight and seeing this long line only in front of Philippine Airlines, where people were waiting for those like high-powered SRAN rap machines to get their cardboard boxes wrapped in layers and layers of plastic. And I remember looking around and thinking, huh, I wonder why do so many Filipino travelers have these massive cardboard boxes?
我记得去到旧金山机场时，由于我的第一次长途国际航班而紧张得不得了，然后看到只有菲律宾航空的前面排着长长的队伍，人们在等待那些高功率的保鲜膜机器，把他们的纸板箱一层又一层地缠上塑料膜。我记得环顾四周，心想，咦，为什么有那么多菲律宾旅客带着这么巨大的纸板箱？
The reason Filipino travelers line up in the airport to wrap 100-pound plus Balak Bion boxes is the same reason why Filipino sons and daughters, mothers, and aunts often live oceans apart from one another. More than 10 million Filipinos live abroad, and over a million more leave the country every year. This migration of Filipinos abroad is also what gives the beloved, complicated, back by unbox, the homecoming box, its name.
菲律宾旅客在机场排队打包100多磅重的巴里克巴延箱的原因，和菲律宾的儿女、母亲、阿姨们常常天各一方、远隔重洋的原因是一样的。有超过1000万菲律宾人居住在海外，每年还有超过100万的人离开这个国家。这种菲律宾人向海外的移民潮，也赋予了这个备受喜爱却又复杂的巴里克巴延箱——这个“返乡箱”——它的名字。
My father left in 1982, and he went specifically to Libya at that point to work in the construction industry. Inigavara is an expert in Filipino migration. She's also from the Philippines, and like many Filipinos grew up with a father working overseas. When Anna was around nine years old, her dad left the Philippines to work in the Middle East as a construction worker.
我的父亲于1982年离开，他当时专门去利比亚从事建筑行业。安娜·加瓦拉是菲律宾移民问题专家。她也来自菲律宾，和许多菲律宾人一样，她是在一个在海外工作的父亲身边长大的。当安娜大约九岁时，她的爸爸离开菲律宾前往中东做建筑工人。
She showed me a picture he sent her when he was in Libya. It is a picture of the desert, you know, very bare piece of land, kind of reddish and color. And there's just one station that you can see and that's where the workers were based. He would write messages to Anna and her mom on the back of the photographs, telling them what he was doing, all the places he was seeing. It says, dear mommy, husbands and wives call themselves mommy and daddy. These are some of the terraces made by our men here. I intend to plant a huge billboard for claiming handiwork of Filipino crusaders for Libyan progress and development with love.
她给我看了一张他还在利比亚时寄给她的照片。那是沙漠的照片，你知道的，是一片非常荒凉的土地，颜色有点发红。你只能看到一个站点，那就是工人们的驻地。他会在照片背面给安娜和她妈妈写信，告诉她们他在做什么，以及他所看到的那些地方。上面写着：“亲爱的妈妈，丈夫和妻子们都自称爸爸妈妈。这些是我们这里的男人建造的一些梯田。我打算竖起一块巨大的广告牌，宣称这是菲律宾十字军为利比亚的繁荣和发展所做出的手工艺成果，爱你们的。”
What does he mean by Filipino Crusaders? I think they saw themselves as individuals who were building up a nation, not as Crusaders building up Libya, but building up the Philippines as heroes, willing to pack up, leave their family behind, and find work abroad to send money home. I think they were quite aware that their remittances were a value to the country, that they were helping the country rise up from a really dire situation at the time. Decades before the birth of the Balak Bayon box, remittances where people abroad sent money home were lifeline to families in the Philippines who were living through one of the Balak Bayon box, remittances where people abroad sent money home were a lifeline
他说的“菲律宾十字军”是什么意思？我想他们把自我视为一个国家的建设者，而不是去建设利比亚的十字军，而是把菲律宾作为英雄来建设，他们愿意收拾行囊，抛下家人，去海外寻找工作以便把钱寄回家。我想他们很清楚，他们的汇款对国家很有价值，他们正在帮助这个国家从当时极其糟糕的处境中站起来。在巴里克巴延箱诞生几十年前，海外人员将钱寄回家的“汇款”就是菲律宾家庭的生命线，当时他们正经历着……巴里克巴延箱诞生几十年前，海外人员将钱寄回家的汇款就是菲律宾家庭的生命线，这些家庭当时正经历着该国历史上最严重的经济危机之一。
to families in the Philippines who were living through one of the worst economic crises the country had ever experienced. That story starts in 1898. The Philippines was a colony of Spain. Spain ruled the Philippines for nearly 400 years. Then in the late 19th century, the Filipino people rose up to fight for independence, but they did not fight alone. The United States helped the Filipino people battle the Spanish colonizers. This was at a moment when the US was in the midst of imperial expansion into former
那个故事始于1898年。菲律宾曾是西班牙的殖民地。西班牙统治了菲律宾近400年。到了19世纪末，菲律宾人民奋起争取独立，但他们并非孤军奋战。美国帮助菲律宾人民抗击西班牙殖民者。当时正值美国向波多黎各和关岛等前西班牙领土进行帝国扩张之际。最终西班牙战败，但美国并没有给予菲律宾独立，而是将菲律宾卖给了美国。你当时听到总统麦金利宣称，美国是以朋友而非敌人的身份来到菲律宾的，这一切都是在“仁慈同化”的幌子下进行的。当时，美国声称这种仁慈同化在某种程度上与西班牙的殖民主义有着神奇的不同。在美国看来，菲律宾不过是这群部落的集合，通过这种仁慈的同化，美国可以将这些公民转变为一个更具纪律性、更守规矩的群体，让他们配得上美国的帝国地位。
Spanish territories, like Puerto Rico and Guam. In the end the Spanish lost, but rather than granting Filipinos their independence, the Spanish sold the Philippines to the US. You hear then President McKinley proclaim that the US is coming to the Philippines as friends, not enemies, and it is under this guise of benevolent assimilation. At the time, the United States claimed that benevolent assimilation was somehow magically different from Spain's colonialism. In the US saw the Philippines as just this collection of tribes, and that through this benevolent
为了从根本上抹杀菲律宾文化并用美国理想取而代之，美国建立了美国医院、配备美国教师的美国学校。你知道的，它甚至发展到教菲律宾人如何吃饭，比如在餐桌上的基本礼仪，如何说话，如何发音某些词。所以这基本上看起来是对菲律宾系统性的抹杀。但麦金利总统的仁慈同化计划有着比单纯将菲律宾人西方化更宏大的目标。
assimilation, America can transform this citizenry into a more disciplined, a more rule-bound population who would be in a fitting of the U.S. of its empire. In an effort to basically erase Filipino culture and replace it with American ideals, the United States set up American hospitals, American schools with American teachers. You know, it even went as far as teaching Filipinos how to eat, you know, proper etiquette when you're at a dinner table, how to speak, how to pronounce certain words. So it looked like a systematic erasure of the Philippines, basically. But President McKinley's project of benevolent assimilation
美国需要农场工人。把被殖民的臣民当作劳动力来源是非常具有战略意义的。美国很快发现，菲律宾最有利可图的资源就是菲律宾人。在20世纪之交，菲律宾人（主要是男性）大规模移民到美国本土和夏威夷做农场工人。
had a bigger objective beyond just Westernizing Filipinos. The US needed farm workers. It was very strategic to turn to your colonized subjects as a labor supply. The United States quickly saw that the Philippines' most lucrative resource was Filipinos. At the turn of the 20th century, Filipinos, mainly men, migrated on mass to the U.S. mainland and Hawaii as farm workers.
为后来寻求海外工作的菲律宾人开辟一条主要移民途径奠定了最初的基石。1935年，美国承诺在10年期满后给予菲律宾独立，但在那10年期满之前，菲律宾在二战期间再次被日本占领。战后，该国在挣扎着融入全球经济。在20世纪60年代，该国近一半的人口生活在贫困之中。费迪南德·马科斯，帕塔特。然后在1965年。在此庄严宣誓，我将全力以赴，数百年来忠实履行菲律宾总统的职责。
The first bricks were laid for what would become a major immigration pathway for Filipinos seeking work overseas. In 1935, the U.S. promised the Philippines independence at the end of a 10-year period, but before those 10 years were up, the Philippines was then occupied again by the Japanese during World War II. After the war, the country struggled to gain footing in a global economy. in the 1960s, nearly half of the country lived in poverty. Hi, 39 being Marcos of Patat. And then in 1965. Hereby solemnly swear that I will pay fully and for the centuries' faithful fill the duties of President of the Philippines.
费迪南德·马科斯（Ferdinand Marcos Sr.）当选总统。马科斯的当选标志着菲律宾历史上最黑暗的时期之一。这个时期不仅导致了巴里克巴延箱的诞生，也将永远重塑菲律宾。当时，菲律宾是该地区的经济领头羊，马科斯在竞选时承诺带来更多的就业机会、发展和经济繁荣。但这一切并没有发生。当时发生了大量的贪污盗用。马科斯政府非但没有振兴整个国家，反而成了一个臭名昭著的盗贼统治政权。所以马科斯家族也因极度腐败而闻名，除了政治腐败之外，他们还因掠夺菲律宾的财富并据为己有而臭名昭著。
Ferdinand Marcos Sr. was elected president. The election of Marcos Eschardin one of the darkest periods of Philippine history. One that would not only lead to the creation of the Balak Bayon box, but would also reshape the Philippines forever. At that time, the Philippines was an economic leader in the region, and Marcos ran on a campaign promise
安东尼·奥坎波（Anthony Ocampo）是一位研究菲律宾侨民的社会学教授。梅尔——马科斯的妻子——因拥有堆满鞋子的房间而闻名，里面有几百甚至几千双鞋子。作为第一夫人，我必须炫耀爱与责任，这样5000万菲律宾人才能看到什么是完美。在他们渴望让菲律宾变得伟大的过程中，他们希望表现得基本上就像皇室一样，看起来极其昂贵和奢华。你知道的，马科斯当时花费了大量的公共资金，这随后导致了通货膨胀，造成了所有这些贸易赤字。马科斯从菲律宾经济中盗取了数十亿美元，为了弥补他偷走的资金，他借了更多钱。
to bring even more jobs, development, and economic prosperity. But that didn't happen. There were a lot of embezzlement taking place. Instead of lifting up the entire country, the Marcos administration became a notorious kleptocracy. So the Marcos were also known as being incredibly, besides like politically corrupt, like they were known for like plundering the wealth of the Philippines and saving it for themselves.
然后这一切就陷入了恶性循环，直到菲律宾背负巨额债务。人们没有工作，靠种植的作物无法维生，没有足够的食物吃。接着在1972年，马科斯宣布戒严。我正在利用这项权力颁布戒严令，以拯救共和国并改革我们国家的社会、经济和政治体制。他暂停了民主，基本上利用他的权力狂热地镇压任何出现的反对声音。他们对菲律宾的设想包括让那些敢于直言反对他们的记者或敢于直言反对他们的活动人士“消失”并折磨他们。到20世纪80年代，失业率居高不下。
Anthony Acompo is a sociology professor who studies the Philippine diaspora. And Mel the Marcos' wife is famously known for having rooms full of shoes, like hundreds or thousands of pairs of shoes. As first lady, I have to flaunt love and duty so that the 50 million Filipinos will see what is perfection. In their desire to make the Philippines great, they wanted to appear, essentially like royalty, and just look incredibly expensive and extravagant. You know, Marcos spent a huge amount of the public's funds at that time, which then created inflation, it created all of these trade deficits. Marcos stole billions of dollars from the Philippine economy, and to offset what he stole, he borrowed more.
人们陷入绝望。而马科斯正在四处寻找解决方案。他最终想到的办法是建立一个以汇款为核心的整体经济。马科斯政权没有选择发展菲律宾本土经济，而是鼓励菲律宾人移居海外，同时保持与菲律宾的联系并将钱寄回来。
And then it just became cyclical to the point that the Philippines was in huge debt. People did not have jobs, could not subsist on what was being grown, did not have enough food to eat. And then in 1972, Marcos declared martial law. I am utilizing this power for the proclamation of martial law to save the republic and reform our social, economic and political institutions in our country. He suspended democracy and basically used his power to fervently suppress any opposition that came. Their vision of the Philippines entailed them disappearing journalists who would speak out against them or activists that would speak out against them and torturing them. By the 1980s, unemployment was high.
他基本上将移民作为菲律宾的一项经济战略来推行。马科斯的计划包含两个方面：让菲律宾人离开国家，然后确保他们把钱寄回家，将他们的收入回流到菲律宾经济中。马科斯的计划具有讽刺意味地被称为“回乡行动”（Operation Homecoming），它利用了美国移民法的一项最新修改。
People were desperate. And Marcos was casting around for a solution. What he landed on was to create an entire economy centered around remittances. Rather than developing the Philippine economy in and of itself, the Marcos regime would encourage Filipinos to move abroad and maintain ties to the Philippines and send money back.
这项法案简单地规定，从今天起，希望移民美国的人将根据他们的技能被准许入境。1965年《移民法》通过了，正是这项立法为所谓的“高技能移民”的到来开辟了途径。那些能够对这个国家、它的增长、它的力量、它的精神做出最大贡献的人，将是首批被允许进入这片土地的人。虽然20世纪初在美国的菲律宾移民主要是农场和工厂工人，但在本世纪后半叶，美国向另一个领域敞开了大门。二战后的护士短缺重创了美国的医疗系统。随后，在20世纪60年代，第二波女性主义浪潮在全国各地高涨，美国女性放弃护理工作去追求其他职业。医院招聘人员不得不求助于菲律宾数以千计接受过美国培训的护士来填补短缺。而菲律宾政府也将其视为一个机遇。因此，马科斯很容易将其视为菲律宾人就业的途径，但也开始将其视为建立汇款经济的一种方式。
He basically launched immigration as an economic strategy for the Philippines. Marcos' plan was twofold. Get Filipinos to leave the country and then make sure they'd send money home, funneling their earnings back into the Philippines economy. Marcos' plan came to be known ironically as Operation Homecoming, and it took
但这一次，不仅是美国的劳动力短缺将菲律宾人吸引到海外。马科斯竭尽全力鼓励菲律宾人去填补世界各地的劳动力需求。香港、新加坡、马德里以及整个中东地区。当时中东正经历石油繁荣，中东国家正在寻找工人。为了鼓励菲律宾人移居海外，马科斯颁布了1974年《劳动法》。该法案基本上通过建立与外国公司合作的招聘机构来确保海外合同工的利益，以保证他们获得良好的工资和基本的劳工权利。但前提是他们出国时必须带着把钱寄回菲律宾的唯一目的。马科斯所鼓励的这种移民，并不是我们通常想到的那种人们为了在其他地方开始更好的生活而离开的移民。这个国家计划依赖于菲律宾人“一只脚在菲律宾，另一只脚永远在外面”。许多出国工作的工人无法带家属，而且海外合同都是临时的。因此，在他们的工作完成后，没有一条通往这些国家公民身份的途径。但许多菲律宾人已经准备好挺身而出，参与“回乡行动”，因为他们不得不这样做。
advantage of a recent change in U.S. immigration law. This bill says simply that from this day forth those wishing to immigrate to America shall be admitted on the basis of their skills. The 1965 Immigration Act passed and that was the legislation that created a pathway for the so-called highly skilled migrants to come. Those who can contribute most to this country, to its growth, to its strength, to its spirit, will be the first that are admitted to this land. While Filipino migrants in the United States and the early 20th century were mainly farm
我认为对于菲律宾人来说，参与“回乡行动”的动力是为了生存。当时你在菲律宾生活的环境并没有真正提供任何其他机会，除了离开。如果你想为你和你的家人过上更好的生活，你必须离开。马科斯给这些回国的人起了一个新名字：巴里克巴延人（Balikbayans）。实际上，这个词是马科斯发起这项真正激进的移民计划、经济计划以鼓励菲律宾人移民时才出现的。每当他们回到菲律宾探亲时，他们就被称为巴里克巴延人。就像我们人民的回归或衣锦还乡。他提升了巴里克巴延人的地位。作为一名巴里克巴延人，你作为新的贵族受到这个国家的欢迎。巴里克巴延人有很多钱。他们赚的美元很坚挺，他们是新英雄。他经常这样说。你们是这个国家的现代英雄，因为你们的汇款为菲律宾做出了巨大的贡献。
and factory workers in the latter half of the century, the U.S. opened the gates to a different sector. Nursing shortages after World War II had crippled the United States' healthcare system. And then, in the 1960s, a second wave feminism swelled throughout the country, American women abandoned nursing to pursue other careers. Hospital recruiters needed to turn to the thousands of American trained nurses in the Philippines to fill the shortage. And the Philippine government also saw it as an opportunity. So it was very easy for Marcos to see that as a pathway for employment for Filipinos, but also started to see that as a way to create
在整个20世纪80年代，巴里克巴延人不仅把钱寄回家，他们还寄东西。尽管他们住在别处，但他们与菲律宾保持着某种联系，因为他们不仅寄现金，还寄物品。有时这些箱子是礼物，让亲人们知道“我在想你们”，但箱子里的绝大多数物品都是家庭在经济危机期间必需的基本物资。于是最终发生的情况是，他们把这些东西装进巴里克巴延箱里带回来，然后发生的事情就是，他们把这些东西装进巴里克巴延箱带回来。所以他们寄出的箱子，你知道的，埃龙热爱解放。它们被称为巴里克巴延箱。
a remittance economy. But this time, it wasn't just US labor shortages pulling Filipinos abroad. Marcos went out of his way to incentivize Filipinos to fill labor needs all over the world. Hong Kong, Singapore, Madrid, and all over the Middle East. The Middle East was experiencing an oil boom during this time, Middle East countries were looking for workers. To encourage Filipinos to move abroad, Marcos passed the 1974 labor code. The law basically
与马科斯旨在为菲律宾带来财富的移民政策不同，这种汇款形式——巴里克巴延箱——是自然而然形成的。当家庭分离时，除了把支票寄回家之外，他们还希望通过其他方式与菲律宾的家人保持联系。
secured overseas contract work by establishing recruitment agencies that work with foreign companies to ensure a good wage and basic worker rights. But only if they went abroad with the sole purpose of sending money back to the Philippines. The kind of migration Marcos was encouraging wasn't the kind we think of when people try and start a better life elsewhere. This national program relied on Filipinos having one foot in the Philippines and one foot out forever. Many of the workers going abroad couldn't bring their families and the overseas contracts were temporary. So there was an pathway to citizenship in those countries after their work was done. But many Filipinos were ready to step up and take part in Operation
那些箱子里的好东西通常大部分包含美国产品，或者你知道的，菲律宾人会想象中代表美国生活方式的东西。我们打开那些箱子时会想：“哦，哇，好吧，巧克力，曲奇，福爵咖啡，高露洁，吉娜茶。”我的意思是，这些就像是奢侈品，对吧？这就是美国式的生活方式。所以它在某种程度上培养了一种感觉：这就是生活在海外的意义。虽然马科斯没有预料到巴里克巴延箱，但它最终巩固了他的移民计划。首先，它具有实用性，因为巴里克巴延人不仅用金钱，还用一箱箱的物品来支持他们的家人；但它也助长了对海外生活的幻想。如果你成了一名巴里克巴延人，你也可以拥有所有这些商品的购买权。
Homecoming because they needed to. I think for Filipinos to ready to step up and take part in Operation Homecoming because they needed to. I think for Filipinos, the incentive is survival. The conditions that you were living in and the Philippines at that time did not really offer any other opportunity except to leave. If you want a better life for you and your family, you have to leave. Marcos gave these people coming home a new name, Balak Bians. It actually is a word that emerged when Marcos
到20世纪80年代中期，就在马科斯签署劳动法成为法律的短短10年后，出国工作的菲律宾人数量增加了近1000%。随着越来越多的巴里克巴延人出国，更多的物品箱子如潮水般涌回。为了推广巴里克巴延箱，菲律宾政府降低了这些箱子的运费，使得物品本身以及运费都免征关税和税收。
launched this really aggressive migration plan, economic plan to encourage Filipinos to migrate. Whenever they come back to the Philippines and they visit what they're called is Balak Bians. like the homecoming or the return of our people. He was elevating the status of Baleekbayan. As a Baleekbayan, you're kind of welcome back to the country as the new aristocrats. Baleekbayan had a lot of money. The dollars that they were earning were strong and they are the new heroes. And he said this quite a bit. You're the modern day heroes of the country because your remittances are contributing so much
但巴里克巴延箱并没有成为今天价值数十亿美元的产业，直到美国的菲律宾企业家发现了一个商机。洛杉矶最早的巴里克巴延箱公司之一实际上只是菲律宾百货商店里的一个小快闪店。加州理工州立大学社会学教授安东尼·奥坎波。他实际上为他的博士论文撰写了关于巴里克巴延箱业务的文章。有趣的是，菲律宾人寄箱子是一个价值数十亿美元的产业，但通常这些公司只是露天购物广场里租来的小地方。就像你能想象的那样，那种典型的加州露天广场，你会看到一家便利店和一个自助洗衣店。那里通常也会有一家巴里克巴延箱公司。
to the Philippines. And throughout the 1980s, the Balakbines weren't just sending money home, they were sending stuff. Even though they were living elsewhere, they kind of maintained ties to the Philippines because they were sending cash, but they were also sending goods. Sometimes these boxes were gifts letting their loved ones know I'm thinking about you, but mostly items inside were essentials that families needed during an economic crisis. And so what ended up happening is they would put them in these public buy-in boxes, bring them back, and ended up happening is they would put them in these
安东尼还研究了箱子的生命周期，它是如何从一个家庭成员传到另一个家庭成员手中的，历经大半个地球。今天，有超过1000万菲律宾人居住在海外，出国的人越多，寄回的箱子就越多。箱子最终被装上一艘船，从长滩港一路航行到马尼拉港，运往菲律宾。想象一下一个两三层楼高的仓库，整个房间里塞满了巴里克巴延箱。这些来自世界各地的巨大箱子。这太疯狂了。
and Balik Bion boxes, bring them back. And so the boxes that they would send, you know, Aaron loves the Liberation. They were called Balik Bion boxes. Unlike Marcos' migration policies designed to bring wealth to the Philippines, this form of remittance, the Balik Bion box, happened organically. When families were separated, they want to remain connected to the families in the Philippines in other ways besides just sending a check home.
作为研究的一部分，安东尼实际上在洛杉矶的一家巴里克巴延航运公司工作过。我们早上六点、七点醒来，开着几乎没有空调的卡车去收巴里克巴延箱。开车去人们家里收巴里克巴延箱。我记得这个60多岁的老妇人字面意思上爬到她的箱子上，开始在上面跳来跳去，就像小孩子在自己的床上跳一样，为了把它合上。就像任何优秀的社会学家一样，他最感兴趣的是箱子对人们意味着什么，他们如何在生活中与它互动。
The goodies in those boxes often contained mostly American products or things that, you know, Filipinos would imagine, you know, represented the state side life. We would open those boxes and think, oh, wow, okay, the chocolates, the twigs, the folders coffee, the cold gate, the Gina Tee. I mean, these were like, my god, luxury goods, right? This is the state-side way of life. And so it kind of cultivated the sense of, this is what it would mean to live overseas. Although Marcos didn't anticipate the Balak Bayon box, it ended up reinforcing his migration plan. First, it was utilitarian in that the Balak Bayons were supporting their families with both money and boxes of goods,
我记得和她聊天。我说：“哦，这个箱子是给谁的？”她说：“哦，是给我儿子在菲律宾的。你知道的，他在那边过得很好。他要结婚了。纳斯特。或者他要去看婚礼。”
but it also helped feed this fantasy of living abroad. If you become a Balak Bayon, you too can have access to all these goods. But the mid-1980s, just 10 years after Marcos signed the labor code into law, the number of Filipinos going overseas to work increased by almost 1,000%. And as more ballot buy-ons went abroad, more boxes of goods came flowing back. To promote the ballot buy-in box, the Philippine government made it cheaper
我看到她脸上的神情变得非常悲伤。她说：“不，我没办法去。”我当时想：“哦，天哪，这就像是那种时刻，你发现箱子本来是用来填补你缺席的空虚的，但它永远无法完全填补这个空虚。”我记得把箱子搬走时，那个年长的菲律宾女性就在阳台上看着我们，你知道的，就像是“照顾好这个箱子，确保它别弄坏了”。当安东尼追踪这些巴里克巴延箱到达菲律宾的收件人手中时，他发现了类似的渴望。
to ship these boxes, making the items and the cost of shipping duty free and tax free. But the Balik Byunbox didn't become the multi-billion dollar industry it is today until Filipino entrepreneurs in the U.S. recognized an opportunity. One of the earliest Balik Byunbox companies in L.A. was actually just in a little pop-up in the Philippine Girls Restore. Anthony O'Compote, the Sociology Professor at Cal Poly. He actually wrote about the BalicBion Boxed businesses for his PhD dissertation. What's funny is that the sending of boxes by Filipinos is like a multi-billion-dollar industry,
他记得有一个特殊的箱子，是一个圣迭戈的父亲寄给他在马尼拉的成年儿子的。他说：“你知道有趣的是什么吗？我爸爸每次寄箱子时，都会给我寄一些起重机的照片，比如建筑起重机。你知道的，那是我八岁时真的很着迷的东西。即使在12、15年后，我爸爸仍然觉得我喜欢起重机。而我不忍心告诉他，我不再是那样的人了。”一个国家建立在汇款之上会是什么样子？
but often these companies are just little rented spots in like a shopping outdoor shopping plaza. Like you can imagine like that quintessential California like outdoor plaza where you'd see like a convenience store and a laundromat. There'd also be like a buy-in-box company there. Anthony also studied the life cycle of the box, how it travels from one family member to the other, all the way across the world. Today, more than 10 million Filipinos live overseas, and the more that go overseas, the more boxes get sent back. The box ends up in a boat that travels all the way to the Philippines from the port of Long Beach to the port of Manila. Just imagine like a warehouse that's two, three
这如何塑造一个国家的身份认同？我想，如果一个国家的经济发展计划是以移民为基础的，那就意味着它的相当一部分公民将在认知上倾向于在他们出生地以外的国家建立生活。我们菲律宾人有着如此紧密的家庭纽带，我们有着牢固的家庭，但这是一个鼓励人们与家人分离的国家。
stories high, but like the whole room is filled with Balechbion boxes. These huge boxes from all over the world. It's bananas. For part of his research, Anthony actually worked for a Balechbion shipping company in Los Angeles. We're waking up at six in the morning, seven in the morning to go pick up Balechbion boxes in a truck with barely inner air conditioning Driving to people's homes to pick up Balic byin boxes. I remember this like 60 something year old woman literally got on top of her box and started jumping on it like a Kid jumping on their bed to get it closed and like any good sociologist He was most interested in what the box meant to people,
几十年来，无论这个巴里克巴延箱多么精美，或者里面有什么好东西，它都无法填补当你的挚爱不再与你同在一个屋檐下时所留下的空白。我的罗拉，当她住在菲律宾时，曾从我的丹尼斯叔叔那里收到过巴里克巴延箱。巴里克巴延箱，它来自库亚德（Kuyadehs）。它来自他的内心。几十年后，她搬到了美国。但来到这里虽然让她能够与她在美国的一些孩子团聚，她却不得不留下她的小儿子阿里尔，他当时还在上学。然后她成了那个寄巴里克巴延箱的人。
how they interacted with it in their lives. And I remember chatting with her. I was like, oh, who's the box for? And she's like, oh, it's for my son and the Philippines. You know, he's doing so well over there. He's getting married. The naster. Or he's going to be going to the wedding.
每当我吃像巧克力这样的东西时，哦，我会想“阿里尔最喜欢这种巧克力”。所以我会去好市多，这就好比当你患上思乡病，想念你的儿子时，我为他们买点东西，然后把它放进箱子里。
And I just saw the mood on her face get really sad. And she's like, no, I'm not going to be able to go. And I just thought, oh wow, this is like one of those moments where you see like the box is kind of supposed to fill the void of your absence, but it never fully fills the void. And I remember taking the box away and the older Filipino woman was like just watching us from the balcony and you know, it was like take care of the box away and the older Filipino woman was like just watching us from the balcony and you know, it was like take care of the box, make sure it doesn't break. Anthony found a similar longing when he followed those Balak Bayon boxes to their recipients in the Philippines.
这让我很高兴，因为我的思乡病会因此而得到治愈。每当我想到他们，把我有而菲律宾也有的东西送给他们。这让我感到快乐。思考着我自己的家庭历史，我真的不知道该如何在这份快乐与我们最初为什么要寄巴里克巴延箱的现实之间找到平衡。
He remembers one box in particular sent by a father in San Diego to his adult son in Manila. He said, you know what's interesting is my dad, whenever he sends a box, he sends me pictures of cranes, like construction cranes. And you know, that's what I was really into when I was eight years old. And my dad, even like 12, 15 years later, he still thinks I'm into cranes. And I don't have the heart to tell him that that's not who I am anymore. What does it look like for a country to be built on remittances?
一方面，每当想到我的罗拉总是与她的孩子远隔重洋，而这背后是超出我们控制的重大历史和经济原因时，我感到难过。但另一方面，当她尝到一块巧克力，知道远在菲律宾的儿子会喜欢它，然后不辞辛苦地买了一箱又一箱这种巧克力寄给他时，这里面有一种美好的东西。你为什么说你的思乡病会治愈？因为每当我想到他们，送给他们一些我这里有而菲律宾也有的东西时。这让我感到快乐。
How does that shape an identity of a country? I think if a country's economic development plan is based on immigration, what that means is that there's a whole lot of its citizens that are gonna be just like cognitively oriented toward building a life outside of the country they were born in. The Latinos, we have such tight-knit families, we have strong families, but it's a country where people are encouraged to separate from their families.
休息过后，加比将为我们讲述那个咸香美味、会导致动脉硬化的物品，你几乎可以在每一个巴里克巴延箱里找到它。广告之后。所以，加比，你回来给我们讲述一个深入且出人意料地深度的故事，关于一个在典型巴里克巴延箱中能找到的特定物品。这实际上是你在去年为WNYC和《大西洋月刊》的播客《实验》（The Experiment）制作的整个三集系列节目的主角。你能告诉我那是什么物品吗？
For decades, and no matter how beautiful this ballic buy-in box is is or whatever nice things are in it, it doesn't feel a gap that happens when a loved one is just not under the same roof as you anymore. My Lola, who received Bion Boxes from my uncle Dennis when she lived in the Philippines. The Bion Box, it came from Kuyadehs. It came from his heart. She moved to the United States decades later. But while coming here allowed her to connect
所以我制作了整个三集系列节目的这个物品，就是咸香美味且出人意料地深奥的午餐肉。那你为什么决定为午餐肉制作整个系列节目呢？好吧，主要的理由是我的菲律宾家族以及整个太平洋岛民都非常喜欢午餐肉。我发现这真的非常迷人。所以我从小到大从未把午餐肉看作是什么好肉，只觉得它是超级加工食品。你知道的，它有点符合那些没有吸引力的过度加工美国食品。而且我大半辈子甚至都不知道自己有没有吃过它。
with some of her kids in the United States, she had to leave her youngest son, Ariel, who was still in school. And then she became the one sending Bionbachs. Whenever I ate something like the chocolate, oh, I remember Ariel loves this chocolate. So I'll go to Costco and it's like when you're home sick, and you miss your son, I buy something for them
后来我遇到了乔伊，我的伴侣，她是菲律宾人。现在我吃午餐肉的频率比我以往想象的要多得多。我很喜欢它。她的家人也很喜欢午餐肉。这成了我现在生活中的一部分。好吧。是的。所以这听起来像是一个非常普遍的故事，一旦你成为了菲律宾社区的一部分，午餐肉就会成为你生活的一部分。
and then put it in a box. and you miss your son, I buy something for them, and then put it in a box. That makes me happy that my home sick will be cured because of that. Thinking about my own family's history, I don't really know how to hold that happiness with the reality of why we send the Balak Bion box in the first place.
从今以后，它就像是个家庭成员。我想去理解为什么菲律宾人会这样。我发现这很大程度上与美国在海外传播民主的追求有关。好吧。我的意思是，在二战期间，午餐肉是美国大兵所谓的“K口粮”中的关键食物来源之一。午餐肉含有大量热量，易于保存，因此是士兵的绝佳选择。当菲律宾成为美国与日本作战的核心战场时，
On the one hand, I feel sad when I think about my Lola always being oceans away from her children, for these big, historical, and economic reasons far beyond our control. But on the other hand, there's something beautiful about her tasting a chocolate, knowing that her son and the Philippines would like it, and then going out of her way to buy boxes and boxes of that chocolate to send to him. Why do you say your home sick will be cured? Because whenever I think of them and I give them something that I have here and that's in the Philippines. That makes me happy.
美国士兵在马尼拉登陆，随之而来的还有午餐肉和他们的食物口粮。为了让大家有个概念，二战期间，为了战争需要，一共生产了1.5亿磅的午餐肉。所以你可以想象当时有多少午餐肉最终流向了菲律宾。哇。是的。美国士兵早上、中午、晚上都吃午餐肉的讽刺之处在于，
When we come back after the break, Gabby tells us about the salty, delicious, artery clogging item that you can find in almost every ballot buy-in box. After this. So, Gabby, you're back to tell us about the in-depth, surprisingly deep story of one specific item found in the typical Balak-Bine box. And it's actually an item that you made an entire three-part series about last year for W and YC and the Atlantic, their podcast called The Experiment. Can you tell me what that item is?
他们对它厌恶至极。他们会用午餐肉向当地人换取任何不是这种毫无特色、粉红且咸的肉块的东西。一块美味但毫无特色、粉红且咸的肉块，不过我可以想象不想每天都吃它。所以他们到处交换，其中很大一部分落入了当地菲律宾人的手中，他们开始爱上它，对吧？正是如此。这绝对是故事的一部分。
So this item that I made an entire three-part series about is the salty, delicious, and surprisingly profound spam. So why did you decide to make an entire series about spam? Okay, so the main reason was that my Filipino family and Pacific Islanders in general love spam. I find this really fascinating. So I grew up never thinking of spam as anything other than not very good meat, like super processed. You know, it's kind of fits into the hyper processed American food that is not appealing. And I don't know if I even had it for most of my life.
但同时，对于经历过日本占领的菲律宾人来说，午餐肉确实承载着非常浓厚的情感价值。我的爷爷，也就是我的罗拉，当美国大兵大批涌入菲律宾时，他大约八九岁，他记得为了躲避日本军队而藏在山里，和家人一起度过了几个饥饿而恐惧的月份。所以当美国大兵开着卡车在尘土飞扬的山路上滚滚而来时，这对他们来说是一件大事。美国大兵会向排在路边的菲律宾人扔东西。比如饼干、香烟、巧克力，吸烟可能有些弊端，当然还有一罐罐的午餐肉。所以我的祖父
And then I met Joy, my partner, and she's Filipino. And now I have spam way more than I ever thought I would. And I like it a lot. And her family loves spam. And it's just one of the things that's part of my life now. Okay. Yeah. So that feels like a very common story to just like, once you're part of Filipino community spam, it's just like going to be part of your life.
讲述了追逐卡车并接住午餐肉罐头的故事。所以我的祖父讲述了卡车驶过时追逐卡车并接住午餐肉罐头的故事。他已经不在人世了，所以我无法问他这个问题，但我总是想知道，这是否是他第一次见到美国人，比如他对美国的最初印象就是二战期间美国大兵向他扔午餐肉罐头？这与这支帮助解放人民然后给饥饿人民食物的军队之间有着强烈的情感联系，这真的非常深刻。没错，所以对他来说，午餐肉代表着自由。这在菲律宾是非常普遍的经历，
So now on, it'll be a family member. And I wanted to try and understand why that is for Filipinos. And like what I found was that has a lot to do with the American quest to spread democracy abroad. Okay. So what I mean is during World War II, Spam was one of the key food sources and what was called the K-Rations for American GIs. Spam has a lot of calories, it stores well, so it's perfect for soldiers. And when the Philippines became a central battleground for the United States to fight the Japanese,
对于我爷爷那一辈人来说。午餐肉象征着奢侈、丰饶和美国自由。在那之后，午餐肉成了菲律宾备受珍视的美味佳肴。这就是为什么它今天仍然是巴里克巴延箱中不可或缺的物品。是的。所以我也理解，对于像你爷爷那一辈人来说，午餐肉代表着
American soldiers landed in Manila and with them, so did the spam and their food rations. And just to put this into context, in total, 150 million pounds of spam were produced for the war effort during World War II. So you can only imagine how much of that is ending up in the Philippines during that time. Wow. Yeah. And the irony of American soldiers
美国文化中所有美好的事物。但我很好奇，这种对午餐肉的喜爱是否延续到了像你这样的人身上，比如你对午餐肉有什么感觉？显然，因为我的爷爷以及他有多么喜爱午餐肉，我对它有着非常深厚的情感依恋。而且，当我小时候拿着好成绩或者其他什么东西从学校回到家时，我妈妈会做午餐肉。炒午餐肉。炒大蒜。哦，太棒了。是的。我很喜欢。但我对它也有一种爱恨交织的关系。没错。
eating spam morning, noon, and night is that they got so completely sick of it. They would trade their spam with locals for literally anything else that wasn't this nondescript slab of pink salty meat. A delicious nondescript slab of pink salty meat, but I can imagine not wanting to eat it every day. And so they traded it far and wide and a lot of it ended up in the hands of local Filipinos who began to love it, right? Exactly. And that's definitely part of the story.
爱是因为对我来说，这始终是一件极其具有菲律宾特色的东西。当我的罗拉还活着的时候，他很喜欢午餐肉。当他来到美国，这里的午餐肉可以随手买到，而且它不再是奢侈品时，他仍然经常吃，几乎每天早餐都吃。直到他被诊断出患有糖尿病。当他被确诊时，他的医生说，午餐肉必须是第一个戒掉的东西。所以对我来说，它带有一种负面色彩，
But also, spam really holds this very sentimental value for Filipinos who went through Japanese occupation. My grandpa, my Lolo, was around eight or nine years old when American GIs started to come to the Philippines and droves and he remembers hiding in the mountains from the Japanese army and spending months feeling hungry and scared with his family. So when American GIs came and started rolling through the dusty mountain roads and their trucks, this was a big deal for them. And the American GIs would throw stuff to Filipinos lining the road. So cookies, cigarettes, chocolate, probably had some downsides with cigarettes, and of course, cans of spam. So my grandfather
你知道的，美国帝国主义和进口到菲律宾的美国罐头食品在公共卫生方面造成了很大的危害。比如，我的罗拉几年前就死于糖尿病并发症。糖尿病……就像我的所有家庭成员都有糖尿病，我并不是说这是因为午餐肉。但这种广泛的现象……
tells the story of chasing after the trucks and catching cans of spam. So my grandfather tells the story of, you know, chasing after the trucks and catching cans of spam as the trucks were kind of rolling by. And he's not alive anymore, so I can't ask him this, but I always wondered if, you know, that was the first time he had ever seen an American, like, of his introduction to, like, America were American GIs tossing cans of spam at him during World War Two. That's a strong sentimental linkage to like this army that is helping free people and then giving them food who people are hungry that's really intense. Right, so to him it was like spam represented freedom. And this was a very common experience in the Philippines
讲述了追逐卡车和接住午餐肉罐头的故事。所以我外公讲过这样一个故事，你知道的，就是追着卡车跑，接住那些从缓缓开过的卡车上扔下来的午餐肉罐头。他已经不在了，所以我无法再问他这件事，但我总是纳闷，你知道的，那是不是他第一次见到美国人，就像他对美国的最初印象，是二战期间美国大兵向他扔午餐肉罐头。这与这支帮助解放人民、给饥饿的人民送食物的军队之间产生了一种强烈的怀旧情感联系，这真的很强烈。没错，所以对（我外公）他来说，午餐肉就代表着自由。这在菲律宾是非常普遍的经历
for people in my low-lose generation. Spam symbolized luxury, abundance, and American freedom. And after that, spam became this prized delicacy in the Philippines. And that's why it's still a quintessential item today in Balak-Bion boxes. Yeah. So I understand that for someone like your low-lowest generation, that spam represents,
对于我外公那一辈人来说。午餐肉象征着奢侈、丰盛和美国的自由。在那之后，午餐肉成了菲律宾备受珍视的美味佳肴。这就是为什么它今天仍然是“巴巴布安”（Balikbayan）礼盒中的经典物品。是的。所以我理解，对于像你外公那样的人来说，午餐肉代表着，
you know, all good things about American culture. But I'm curious if that love of spam extends to someone like you, like how do you feel about spam? So obviously I have a really sentimental attachment to it because of my grandpa and how much he loved it. And also, when I would come home as a kid with like good grades or something from, you know, from school, my mom would make spam. Fried spam. Fried garlic. Oh, lovely. Yeah. I love that. But I also have this love-hate relationship with it. Right.
你知道的，美国文化中所有美好的事物。但我很好奇，这种对午餐肉的热爱是否延续到了像你这样的人身上，比如你对午餐肉有什么感觉？显然，因为我外公以及他有多么喜爱午餐肉，我对它有着非常深厚的感情。而且，当我小时候带着好成绩或其他什么好消息放学回家时，我妈妈会做午餐肉。煎午餐肉。炸蒜头。哦，太棒了。是的。我很喜欢。但我也对它有一种爱恨交织的复杂感情。没错。
Love because it's always been this distinctly Filipino thing to me. And when my Lolo was alive, he loved spam. And when he came to America where spam was freely available and it was an luxury item, he would still eat it all the time, like every day for breakfast. That was until he got diagnosed with diabetes. And when he was diagnosed, his doctor was like, the spam needs to be the first thing to go. So there's this negative connotation for it with me,
爱是因为对我来说它一直是极具菲律宾特色的一样东西。我外公生前非常喜欢午餐肉。当他来到美国、这里的午餐肉可以随意买到且不再是什么奢侈品时，他仍然经常吃，几乎每天早餐都吃。直到他被诊断出患有糖尿病。确诊后，他的医生说，午餐肉必须是首先要戒掉的东西。所以它对我来说带有一种负面的含义，
you know, American imperialism and American candidates imported to the Philippines have done a lot of harm in terms of public health. Like my Lolo, for example, died of complications from diabetes a few years ago. Diabetes is in like all of my family members have diabetes and I'm not saying that it's because of spam. But the widespread
你知道的，美帝国主义和输入到菲律宾的美国食品在公共卫生方面造成了很大的危害。比如我外公，几年前就死于糖尿病并发症。糖尿病……我所有的家庭成员都有糖尿病，我并不是说这是因为午餐肉。但这种广泛的传播
export of unhealthy processed American foods and the reverence for it, processed foods like spam, for me, is part of the real public health issue in the Philippines, and diabetes and heart disease are some of the leading causes of death in the Philippines. Yeah. And this is pretty widespread. Like everything that we export that's processed and high in fat and high in salt and high in sugar, you know, this is something not unique to the Philippines.
美国不健康的加工食品的出口及其受到的盲目崇拜，像午餐肉这样的加工食品，对我来说是菲律宾真正公共健康问题的一部分，糖尿病和心脏病是菲律宾人的主要死因。是的。这非常普遍。就像我们出口的所有加工食品一样，高脂肪、高盐、高糖，你知道，这并非菲律宾独有。
Right, and it's widespread, especially throughout the Pacific Islands. Wherever American GIs went during World War II, they left a trail of fatty, salty, American processed foods in their wake. And spam has become really integrated into local cuisines and places like Hawaii, Guam, American Samoa, and all of those places
没错，而且这很普遍，尤其是在整个太平洋群岛。二战期间美国大兵走到哪里，就在哪里留下一串串高脂肪、高盐的美国加工食品。午餐肉已经真正融入了夏威夷、关岛、美属萨摩亚等地的当地饮食中，而所有这些地方
have staggeringly high rates of diabetes and heart disease. So the story I thought I was telling through the spam series was, you know, that spam was delicious and a relic of imperialism the end. But when I started researching spam and especially when I went to visit spam's headquarters in Austin, Minnesota, that's when I really opened a Pandora's can, so to speak.
的糖尿病和心脏病发病率高得惊人。所以，我以为我在午餐肉系列中讲述的故事是，午餐肉很美味，而且是帝国主义的遗物，故事结束。但当我开始研究午餐肉，尤其是当我参观位于明尼苏达州奥斯汀的午餐肉总部时，我才真正打开了一个“潘多拉的罐头”，可以这么说。
I found out that the factory that makes spam actually played a huge role in the American labor movement in the 1980s. And that story led us into a larger story about immigration, the history of meat packing, the evolution of labor, and it ended up being that the story of spam criss-crosses like decades and continents and it touches some modern pressing questions about food, family, and how we want to work to put food on the table. Well, it is all really fascinating stuff. So people want to hear more and I really recommend they do. They should check out WNYC's and the Atlantic's The Experiment Podcast from last spring. There's a three-part series on spam how the American Dream got canned. Thank you so much, Gavry. I really appreciate it. Thank you.
我发现制造午餐肉的工厂实际上在20世纪80年代的美国劳工运动中发挥了巨大作用。这个故事引导我们走向了关于移民、肉类加工史、劳工演变等更大的故事，最终发现午餐肉的故事纵横交错于数十年和各大洲之间，它触及了关于食物、家庭以及我们如何通过工作来谋生的现代紧迫问题。这确实是非常引人入胜的内容。所以如果人们想听更多，我强烈建议他们去听。他们应该去看看WNYC和《大西洋月刊》去年春天推出的播客节目《实验》（The Experiment）。这是一个关于午餐肉的三部分系列节目，讲述了美国梦是如何被装进罐头的。非常感谢你，加夫里。我真的很感激。谢谢。
99% Invisible was Produced This Week by Gabrielle Burbe and edited by Kelly Prime with additional help from Christopher Johnson, Jacob Moltenado Medina, Swan Rial, and Vivian Le. Mixed by Martin Gonzalez, Music by Director of Sound, Swan Rial. Delaney Hall is the Senior Editor, Kurt Colstad is the Digital Director, the rest of the team. Is Chris Barube, Bosch Mdahn, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Robin Rodriguez.
本周的《99%无形》由加布里埃尔·伯比（Gabrielle Burbe）制作，凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）编辑，克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、雅各布·莫尔特纳多·麦地那（Jacob Moltenado Medina）、斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）和维维安·莱（Vivian Le）提供了额外帮助。马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里亚尔负责。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑，库尔特·科尔stad（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监，其余团队成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、博施·麦达恩（Bosch Mdahn）、杰森·狄龙（Jason Dillion）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。本周特别感谢罗宾·罗德里格斯（Robin Rodriguez）。
Gabrielle hopes to produce more perfect to show about the Supreme Court for WNYC Studios, which will be releasing its new season in the spring. I am very excited about this. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family. Now I had quartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California.
加布里埃尔希望为WNYC工作室制作更多关于最高法院的精彩节目，该节目将于春季发布新一季。对此我感到非常兴奋。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一员。现在我们在美丽、繁华的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城潘多拉大厦以北六个街区办公。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. While it lasts, we're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. You're listening to a Stitcher podcast from SiriusXM. Thank you for sticking with us in 2022. I'll see you next year. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@节目 99PI org。只要还在，我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及《99%无形》的每一期往期节目。你正在收听的是来自SiriusXM的Stitcher播客。感谢你在2022年一直陪伴我们。我们明年见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。